There we go.
Welcome back, Master and Ma'am!
Hello!
Hello, hello.
I'm supposed to be tired, but thank you for doing the live.
No, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hello!
Hello, everybody.
I sound maybe a little bit better today.
Maybe.
Maybe I sound a little bit better.
I think.
Sick.
Hello.
Did I sound much better than yesterday?
Yeah!
Yippee!
Sick.
Sick in the head.
Sick in the mind.
Sick in the spirit.
You guys sick in the body.
Probably.
Thank you again for singing Happy Birthday for my daughter.
I'll put a recording of it.
Sorry, I don't usually do like the...
Wait.
Wait, hold on.
My head is messed up.
Not just my head being messed up.
Hold on.
I'm actually messed up.
There we go.
I'm messed up in the head.
I'm not used to... I don't usually do like the interchanging BGM, so it threw me off.
But yeah, of course.
Actually, I have some birthdays that I missed yesterday.
Since I was doing the stream.
Good morning.
Good morning!
Chi Papa, I don't understand the reference.
I have not played the Monster Girl Quest with Paradox, the new one.
So, I don't understand.
I saw someone super chat earlier.
They were like, return to Hora Hora.
My friend's toddler is watching.
She loves you so much.
Can you say...
Hi Riley!
Hello, hello!
Hi Riley, hi!
I like how so much of the pre-chat became talking about Monster Girl Quest.
Just all because of my thumbnail.
That's so funny.
It really became like such a conversation.
Hi Jack!
Oh coughing medicated Minto baby, can you give us your best coughing baby impression?
Welcome back for real for real Minto.
Okay.
Best coughing baby impression.
And you have to get like the...
You have to do like the mouth, you know.
Chi Papa is from the OG game, that's what Sylph says.
Oh, I don't remember.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, wait.
We're gonna talk Monster Girl Quest in a minute, okay?
We're gonna talk it in a minute.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
That's my coughing baby.
That's not me actually coughing, but...
You know how like babies, like when they...
They're like...
They like...
They like release it from their soul.
They release it from their soul.
That's me actually coughing.
Oh gosh.
Minto, you're all soul.
I know!
I know.
But...
Yeah, Monster Girl Quest.
Okay, it's been a really long time...
Since I've played Monster Girl Quest.
Minto Doki came in today.
Yippee!
Thank you.
I honestly wanna play it on stream.
Because it's been so long.
And I also have not played Chapter 3.
So I'm like...
Because when I played it, Chapter 3 was not out yet.
So I'm just like...
I've been...
Is there a stream friendly version?
No.
But...
I have...
I looked at the game earlier.
And...
I can export all of the CGs from it.
Like all of the images from it.
And if I manually censor...
Each and every single one...
If I manually censor each and every single one...
And then re-import it...
Into the game...
lol I think...
I think I could do it.
Probably.
Everybody is playing HuniePop right now.
So I'm just like...
What's the difference, you know?
Don't miss any.
I know, right?
That would be terrifying.
That's dedication.
Yeah, but I really wanna play.
I've been talking about playing Chapter 3 for so long.
And honestly, it's just kind of...
Thanks for the art.
Thanks for the 5%!
If I...
I have to get back...
It's been so long since I've played the first two.
So I would have to play those.
I remember the story.
But I don't remember like specific parts of it.
You know what I mean?
And...
lol What about spoilers?
I guess I would have to get someone to help me with part 3.
Probably.
But I've played 1 and 2.
So I totally...
You know, I'm not...
I'd be fine, I think.
Ew, drippy nose.
I'm like that Pokemon.
The one that you want to beat up.
I always want to beat up that nasty little bear.
Lunch for Tissue.
Thank you.
Cup Chew.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm thirsty, let me drink from that.
I'm not gonna read that.
Mr. Kaigai, happy birthday!
Kaigai Nikki.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Mr. Kaigai Nikki.
Wait.
Wait, I have two more from yesterday.
But I couldn't sing.
So these are two from yesterday.
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Dice Bag Games.
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Koyuki.
Okay, I think I'm caught up.
I wrote this down earlier, because I saw them yesterday.
But I was doing sponsor streams, so I was like...
I can't just interrupt the stream for it.
So sorry, that's a little late.
I just started my adventuring in Tokyo in order to get your BGM.
Hope you feel better.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I'm sick too, sisters.
Sicky sisters.
Can you tell us about your comic yet?
Yeah, I have a lot I want to talk about.
I wrote things down so I wouldn't forget.
Will you play Rance 2?
Was this the beginning of my Edoge arc on my stream?
On my channel?
I don't think I can get away with...
I wonder what's the limit I can get away with.
Thank you for the 50 gifts!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Hi!
Oh gosh.
Sorry, I didn't take all of the sleepy time medicine.
So I only took half.
Because it tasted bad.
But...
Just ask Kei-san.
Hey, she's on Twitch.
I don't do Twitch here.
She got banned.
Yeah, I know.
On Twitch.
That's what I'm saying.
She got banned on Twitch.
She didn't get banned on YouTube.
But I'm wondering, like, for some of the HCNs...
If...
Thank you for the 50 gifts!
Thank you!
If I would get in trouble for, like, the sounds.
If I would think it's like an ASMR, you know.
You know how some people get age...
Age restricted because of Kei...
Sorry, I read Kei-san.
Not Kei-san.
Because of ASMR...
Streams, even though the ASMR is, like, fine.
Thank you for the 2747 karaoke stream.
That made my cross-country holiday excursion more fun.
Sorry, you probably had to hear repeats, though.
But I'm glad you liked it.
Thank you.
Happy New Year, Kero-san.
Thank you!
Now, so...
Recovering from COVID.
No!
Looking forward to the Eroge arc.
We'll see, though.
We can try...
You watch a VTuber play with all the sussy sounds intact?
Still up?
Not sure if monetized.
I don't really care about the monetization, I'll be honest.
As long as I don't get, like, my YouTube...
Whatever partnership, I guess, is what it's called, taken away.
But I don't mind if, like, a stream gets demonetized.
I don't know.
But we'll see.
Maybe we'll run with, like, the first game.
And then see from there.
I know that Monster Girl.
But I've been a big fan of Monster Girl Quest for a long time, for those who don't know.
Someone asked earlier what my favorite Monster Girl is.
I mean, it's probably basic, but I do love Alice a whole lot.
Like, she is peak design for me.
And it's been a long time since I played, so it's kind of hard for me to say...
From who I remember.
Of course I remember, like, Touch Fluffy Tail and all that.
Actually...
Before Matara debuted in Bishoujo...
I was the one who was just like...
Hey, girl.
You should contact Kenko Cross.
That was me.
I was like, if you want, you know...
If you want peak design, just ask.
I love Monster Girl.
Very much.
I have, like...
Actually, do I?
I don't know if I'm current current.
I have Mangos 1 through 17 of Monster Musume.
Is that current current?
I don't collect Mango very much, but...
When I do...
18 just came out.
I have to pick it up.
Yeah.
I'm struggling not to say something unwise about the thumbnail art today.
It's okay.
It made me feel unwise too.
So maybe one day... Maybe one day...
I was just like, oh man, if I could, like...
Censor them really quickly, the pictures.
I was like, I'll play it next week, but...
I...
Don't think I can in time.
It might be a while.
Wow, Jay, thanks for the peak!
Hope you get well soon, but stay freaky.
Thank you!
Oh yeah, Ashes, I saw your dono earlier.
Sorry, I was talking.
Mint vs the Hat Man.
Who would win?
Betting on the Hat Man.
Who is the Hat Man?
Hat Man.
She doesn't know.
Huh?
Hat Man is a Benadryl hallucination.
What?
I'm on the TL team.
Do you want me to whip you up a mild censor for...
No!
Wait, what?
No way!
Of like...
Original Monster Girl Quest?
No, it's okay though.
I don't want you to go through that trouble though.
It's okay.
Is she sick?
I'm sick in the head.
Dona Dona has an NSFW toggle for sayings and vowels.
No way!
I didn't know that.
Why would you turn it off?
Why?
Reminded me.
Reminded you of me.
Sick freaks.
For the story.
Okay though, but with Monster Girl Quest...
I kind of want to play it because like...
Like on stream rather is because...
Because...
Sorry.
Oh god.
Is because the story is actually so good.
It's literally one of those things.
I came for the plot and I stayed for the plot.
Type of...
Type of stories.
You know what I mean?
It's actually so good.
Like...
Like unironically, it's so so good.
Favorite interspecies reviewers character.
Oh, I only watched a couple episodes of that.
Because I was actually watching it on...
Oh gosh, I don't remember what...
Platform it was on.
I don't have that anymore.
HiDive or whatever.
And then they took it off because they're stupid.
Funimation?
Was it Funimation?
It was so disappointing.
So I never actually finished it.
Because I sometimes get lazy when it comes to finding other ways.
It was just a couple episodes that I watched.
It was good though.
It was good from what I watched, yeah.
Couldn't handle the freak.
So sad.
But I'll finish it someday.
I'll finish it someday.
Show was peak.
What about for Paradox?
I want to finish the original story first though.
I think.
Before I go into Paradox.
Since Paradox is...
It's like...
From what I understand, it's an alt story but also the gameplay is different too, right?
It's a side project.
No, it's okay.
Don't worry about it.
Thank you though.
I really appreciate it.
Paradox is very long.
Is it now?
Finish the original first Paradox.
Might spoil the early one.
I gotta finish all the stuff with the angels in the third chapter.
TL site sponsor win.
lol
What the heck?
Why are there so many translator team people here?
I want to...
Like I said, it's been so long since I played it.
That I...
That I want to...
Want to go back through it for the first two games.
Freaks assemble.
I guess the thumbnail really did wonders, huh?
The thumbnail really...
It was not clickbait.
We're talking about Monster Girl Quest.
Maybe I should have saved it for when I stream Monster Girl Quest.
lol
Reporting for duty.
Did you draw the thumbnail?
No, no, no.
The thumbnail artist is in the description.
MapleSides.
Thumbnail game too strong.
Should I get that as an outfit?
YouTube would really hate me, I think.
Maybe.
Sometimes they're like that with...
With...
Too much skin.
If I were blue, maybe it'd be okay.
Did the artist know or is it Quinten?
I've talked about liking Monster Girl Quest before.
And it's Hero of the Snake.
It's perfect.
Perfect.
I actually did a game review speech in high school on...
Wait.
I did a game review speech in high school.
Paradox is indeed a full sequel.
In high school.
I'm pretty sure that's when I played it too.
It's our secret.
Monster and ghost girls are indeed the best.
Technically, I am a monster girl.
I'm in the Monster Girl encyclopedia.
Logan, thank you for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
Guys, I think I'm really weak.
I already feel my head getting so dizzy.
I'm gonna google the hat, man.
I'm scared.
Hat, man.
Scary.
Does he look like the guy from Curious George?
Don't push yourself.
I'm all good.
Don't worry.
I just didn't think it would hit so fast.
Actually, I might go get some dinner.
Pretty good.
Thank you for the aqua soup.
Welcome back, Mito.
And congrats on this great Touhou cover.
Thank you.
I really, really appreciate it.
For only three 570 energy drinks.
From 2026.
I didn't have dinner yet, but easy.
I will.
Don't worry.
I went and bought some pre-made sushi.
Why would you take sleep medicine and not sleep?
Well, I didn't sleep so much last night because of the jet lag.
And I was like, I gotta force myself today.
I'll give you a small tip on stream lives, Mito.
Love your singing.
Congrats on the collab.
Thank you.
Good playlist.
Thank you for the aqua soup.
But why would you...
Why would you send...
Stream lives, sorry.
I think it's backed up because of some of the gifting.
But why would you send...
Why would you send stream lives?
Don't know.
And then aqua... Don't know.
Stop it.
It's small.
What do you mean by that?
Hold on.
I'm gonna go look prematurely.
I'm gonna look at the ones that haven't come through yet.
They have a titanium.
Thank you.
Mito's back.
Yippee.
I just discovered a new face I can make, you guys.
Look at this.
I got sick the same time as you.
I think you haunted me.
I might have.
I'm really sorry.
Don't worry, man.
I'll take sleep meds and we'll fight the hat man so you can sleep in peace.
Please fight the hat man for me.
My mouth is so small!
Did you guys watch the cover?
Did you guys listen to it?
I'm actually so...
Uh...
Uh, what's the word?
Self-conscious of it.
It was awesome.
Today at work, too.
Oh, there it is.
I think they're coming through now.
You should put it on Spotify.
I don't think that's up to me, though.
I think that's up to them.
Listen to the cover on repeat for an hour while shoveling snow.
You're gonna get sick of it if you do it like that.
I heard you're sick with strong.
Let me fight it.
The only cover I know is your one of Santa Baby.
So many people have been talking about the Santa Baby.
Santa Baby.
We...
Shoveled snow yesterday, got a cold.
No!
Everybody's getting sick, huh?
Everybody, huh?
Trying to be healthier for 2025.
And the cover is perfect for running PGM.
Oh, let's go.
Didn't miss the...
Transformers 1 discussion.
No!
Guys, we...
Okay.
ViviCore, thank you so much.
I get to thank you.
You guys didn't tell me that Transformers 1 was...
Was animated.
I thought it was gonna be...
Like, I think actually Michael Bay produced it.
But I didn't realize that it was going to be...
I thought it was going to be like a live action, you know, like another one of those.
Is it animated?
Yes!
And it's so good!
It's so good!
I thought it was going to be like Michael Bay's slop, you know, but...
What's the Santa, baby?
He was like, you're so cute.
Thank you.
I'm pretty sure though...
Pretty sure Michael Bay helped produce this one.
And then also Steven Spielberg.
And also...
Rise up!
Sorry, I didn't tell you.
I failed you.
It's okay.
I didn't watch any trailers or anything, so I guess it's on me too.
The part that sucks though is that it was advertised like it was a kid's film.
I...
See it.
Why it, like, would be advertised that way.
It's very...
I think it's like one of those types of movies that's like all ages.
You know what I mean?
Anyone can enjoy it.
Badassatron.
I...
But because Megatron...
Because they kept calling him D...
In my brain, I kept calling him DD Megadoodoo.
Because, you know, Megatron.
But I was like, oh, DD Megadoodoo.
You guys know that video.
You guys know that clip of like the...
It's like a...
No?
Okay, hold on.
Let me pull it up.
Hold on, let me pull it up.
It's super duper short.
DD Megadoodoo.
It's like the shortest thing ever.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
DD Megadoodoo.
Did you see both end credit scenes?
I...
I saw the one of like the Decepticons.
And I saw the one where B...
Kills his friend or whatever.
Both of them.
Is that the ones you're talking about?
Like, come on man, Happy New Year.
Happy New Year!
Okay, hold on.
Let's watch DD Megadoodoo real quick.
Real quick, real quick.
Oh, sorry.
I cropped it kind of weird.
But that's fine.
I'll just crop it on this side too.
There we go.
Okay, DD Megadoodoo.
Oh my god, I just realized this.
I was like, wow, this BGM is going for so long.
It's because it's a two hour version.
When the hell did I download that?
Okay.
Final goodbyes to this fallen Louisville police officer.
DD Megadoodoo.
I'm sorry.
Mangudoo.
Final goodbyes to this fallen Louisville police officer.
DD Megadoodoo.
I'm sorry.
Mangudoo.
It's so messed up.
DD Megadoodoo.
I'm sorry.
It's so bad.
I don't envy being a newscaster like that at all.
I think I would be like...
You know how I mispronounce stuff all the time already.
Where I say things wrong or...
I type things weird.
316 is actually a reference to Megatron's original toy in the Takara Transformers line.
It was his collection number.
No way, I had no idea about that.
Transformers 1 mention.
Must send money.
Seriously, the story I've been wanting to see.
Animated for years.
And the fact that it got slipped on kills me.
It was a love letter to the franchise I love.
Glad my Kamiya-shi liked it.
I loved it.
It was so good.
DD Megadoodoo.
I couldn't stop thinking about it.
It was just so good.
Did you see Nosferatu yet?
No, I haven't seen that one actually.
Most of the things that I knew...
Well, I didn't know anything about Transformers 1.
But anything that I knew about it...
About it being a good movie...
Was from that one Transformers hype guy on Twitter.
So...
I...
Wearing TF shirt and mintos and all these...
I'm talking about TF1.
I want to see Nosferatu though.
I heard that he's uncircumcised.
Is that true?
No.
Oh, I saw also that with the...
Yes, actually.
I saw that also for Transformers.
That...
Lucasfilms also helped with the animation.
Craziness.
And then there's like Scarlett Johansson.
Johansson?
Scarlett Jo...
Jo-mama?
What's her name?
She's in it too.
I meant to hope you had a good day.
I heard you got sick so...
Also happy 30th Ace Combat Anniversary New Year.
Happy 30th Ace Combat Anniversary New Year.
Sorry you're under the weather.
Here's hoping your cold is as short as...
Stop!
I had it right?
Scarlett Megadoodoo.
Does the new Linkin Park singer transform...
Wait, what?
Trash Dracula.
Yeah, Scarlett voices Elita Wan.
I'll forever say Scarlett Jo-mama from now on.
Scar...
Scarlett Megadoodoo.
Hypothetically, if I did a Gingerbread Minto cosplay in the style of Phantom of the Opera...
What has gotten you on your Phantom of the Opera kick?
What hypothetical color scheme for a three-piece men's suit would Mint hypothetically recommend?
It has to be mint though, right?
Mint and gold.
Brown highlights?
I don't know.
Get creative with it.
Welcome back, Mint.
Resident Lurker here.
There's a lot I want to say about...
Oh.
Good playlist.
Oh my god!
That's way too much, please.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Holy moly, no, it's way too much though.
Puskai, Kazem, thank you so much for the first ever Super Chat.
Good luck with... Oh wait, I was going to say good luck with college, but you graduated!
Congrats!
I always wondered, but never asked.
Do you have control on the character limit on membership supers?
They only get 50, not sure if on purpose.
I don't think I have control over that.
If I do, I've never seen a way to change it.
Oh, thanks for the...
Thank you.
I have lots of fun in Japan.
I have Japan stories to talk about too.
I think it's because of $2 membership.
FeelBetterMental, thank you!
Interesting, I never knew that that was...
That that had a direct...
Had a direct...
Impact.
Sorry, I won't make any higher tiers.
I have no plans of making higher tier memberships.
I would like to keep it pretty affordable.
But also, I'm sometimes bad with...
Doing like...
The...
You know.
Membership streams.
John Nuclear, thanks for the 10 gift card!
Mento, you reminded me of...
The criminal who was caught a few years ago.
Who legally changed his name to Beezow Doodoo.
What?
Honestly, if I became a criminal...
Which I already am...
I might change my name to that.
I couldn't get a plushie in time, so I settled for the Doki.
Wait, Zack, I think the plushies are still up though.
They're just still on the second patch.
Wish I knew what I was getting it before I bought it.
What do you mean?
You bought it without even knowing it!
VTuber doesn't want our money.
No.
Made Megadoodoo.
Minky Megadoodoo.
Why does a Minky Megadoodoo work?
It works!
It works.
Let me spend more money on you.
Minky Megadoodoo.
Give Mint more money while it's in.
Are the plushies being delivered already?
No, I think they're gonna start.
End of this month, maybe?
Beginning of next month?
New Eroge channel name.
That's where I have to stream all the Eroge stuff just in case this one gets taken down.
I just got a new job.
Saltycat, congrats!
Congrats!
Good thing we like being hated.
Vector Tom, thanks for the thank you.
Thank you guys for all the superchats, I really appreciate it.
Appreciate it so much.
Apey, a little bit.
There's some other stuff I want to talk about my Japan trip today.
I also want to talk about my 2025 goals.
Let's come up with a goal list.
I have some.
But I want to come up with a proper list of goals and things.
For paying my Minky Megadoodoo tax.
I want to come up with a proper goal list, right?
Nippon.
I keep a ferret!
Welcome to membership.
Sounds like my favorite kind of ferret.
We're three.
It's coming!
It's coming, don't worry.
She hates us for superchatting.
I hate you, always.
$100 a month membership.
That's an actual scam.
I would call it a scam.
I want to go back to Japan.
I
miss you, everyone.
No way.
I just got back.
I went to Komiket.
And I...
I also went to my favorite VTuber's...
No, sorry.
Not VTuber.
Oh gosh.
I think the medicine is kicking in.
My favorite idol's disbanding live concert.
Saw your TF1 tweet.
Eight times in theaters.
I...
It's great you got to see them last time.
For Transformers...
I don't...
Why was it so BL?
Squishes mean those puffs puffs.
What does that mean?
Stop!
Don't touch there.
It was always BL.
Was it really?
It's just so...
Did I just hear you complain about BL?
No, no, no.
I think it was a good thing.
Trust, trust.
I think it was great.
I just was like...
You know, when people were like...
I didn't expect it to be.
Starscream, Skyfire for life.
I'll be honest.
My knowledge of Transformers is a bit limited.
Because I...
Watched...
I watched...
Beast Wars.
Which is not exactly...
Not exactly the same.
Beasties.
So...
But you know, it was really exciting too to be like...
Oh my god!
There's Starscream!
You know, stuff like that.
In this movie too.
And like...
Arach... Arach...
What's her name?
Glad to see you back in the meantime.
I really miss you.
Thank you, Katie.
Katie?
Thank you.
One of my favorite Vtubers.
I'm so happy, thank you.
Arachnid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Arach...
Black Arachnia.
But what...
I'm trying not to make a stake her for...
The one in Beast Wars.
Anything after Beast Wars is in canon.
I will not be taking questions.
And I will offer no explanations.
Air Arachnid.
Yeah, yeah.
Air Doodoo.
Oh,
it's...
I...
How do you say it?
Air Arachnid or Eye Arachnid?
Mmm.
Transformer fact, the original Skyfire Jetfire toy was repackaged VF-1 Valkyrie from Hot Cross.
No way!
Air, like Air Jordan.
Or you know, just... Air.
Air.
Air Arachnid because she's a flying vehicle.
Oh, that's so cool!
Oh, I didn't realize that's why she was called it.
I really liked her though.
Yeah, she turned into like the drone looking thing.
That's so cool.
Hola, Minto.
Hola!
The atmosphere with the 24-7 VOD stream chat has been incredible.
Did you stop by to check it out from time to time?
Very few, very few.
Yeah, I liked her a lot.
And...
You're a soup.
Thank you, Jed.
Tell your sickness that you need to be healthy.
The stream has your request.
True.
Finally, Mint Snake.
Finally.
Actually, it really sucked because...
Some people were like, oh wow, Mint's voice is so dead because she was screaming so much at the concert.
But no.
My voice was like this before the concert.
And that made screaming at the concert not very easy.
So I was so sad.
I wanted to scream my heart out.
I've got about 200 Transformers figures.
And 32.
Oh, those are Optimus Primes.
Thumbnail doesn't awake something dark?
What if I wanted to awaken something dark?
Kingdom Hearts?
I've already played Kingdom Hearts before.
Something that would you rather maximize or terrorize?
Can I maximize my terror?
Terrorization.
Can I terrorize to the maximum degree?
lol
Hot dog.
Sick in bed?
Why is everybody sick?
I'm home.
Feel better, Triforce?
You've been secretly infected with Fox- Koyuki!
Did you say I wished you a happy birthday earlier?
Sorry, I missed it yesterday.
Fox...
Died.
She died.
But I really did like Transformers so much.
And...
Oh gosh, I feel it kicking in.
Hold on.
I'm gonna go get my food real quick.
Sorry, I know it's pretty early in the stream for me to go get some food.
But I'll be really fast.
Like I said, it's already mid.
VRB is super duper fast.
Okay?
I told you I'd be fast.
I don't know actually how fast that was.
I stood up in the world's span.
It was spinning, baby.
The world is spinning, baby.
From the medicine.
It's been 30 minutes?
Don't lie to me.
I'm not that...
I'm not...
I'm not that hungover.
It does feel like...
I've never had a hangover before.
But when you take medicine like this, it does feel like you have a hangover, doesn't it?
Go to sleep?
I actually have a meeting in two hours, so...
You guys are gonna make sure I don't fall asleep.
So I can get to my meeting.
Okay?
Why do you take sleep medicine?
So I can sleep.
Dummy.
Megatron, wake up.
That guy is so silly.
He's like...
Megatron is so stupid.
He gets betrayed once and is just like...
I'm not gonna let this happen to me again.
That guy is so stupid.
You took sleep medicine before a meeting?
What do you think of the Snake Eater remake?
I'm excited for it.
Is Oshie still mad at you?
I think
I...
My only gripe is I wish that they had like...
I wish they had a...
Like I understand that they were miner guys.
Little miner bots.
And that they were always there.
But like, I wish there was something a little bit more to making Megatron switch.
Because he's like... He's like... Oh gosh, what's his name?
Sussy Prime?
He's not really... Sus... Sus... Suspicious Prime.
What's his name?
I can't remember.
Sentinel Prime!
I knew I started with an S.
I couldn't remember.
Sentinel Prime.
He's like, Sentinel Prime took everything from me.
But I'm like, you're no different from Optimus Prime, you know?
Everybody lost something.
So I wish there was a little bit more of a oomph.
Megatron just basically went F everything.
I know!
He got burned once and was just like...
That's all it took.
Part of D16's downfall into Megatron is that Megatron was always inside him.
He's just a sensitive guy.
He's just a sensitive baby.
He was always an angry person, he just hid it well.
If you rewatch it, you can notice the subtleties of how he acts.
Well, he did always kind of like, you know...
Optimus would be like... Sorry, I can't remember Optimus's...
Not Optimus's name.
But he would be like, yeah, I'm gonna do this thing!
Orion Pax, you guys are so good at remembering things.
Thank you.
Orion would be like, yeah, let's do the thing!
And D would be like, no!
What the hell is wrong with you?
But he should have trusted... He should have had faith in his friend.
He should have had faith in his friend.
His comrade.
His brother.
I always wanted to...
I love how much that's picking up on Twitter and stuff.
Everyone's talking about the brother.
I always wanted a brother.
Did you know that's actually Scar singing and not Mufasa?
I didn't know that actually.
I kind of know the story for Mufasa.
Kind of.
I always wanted a brother.
A guy who's post went viral.
I ended up listening to it so much he likes it now.
That's Stockholm Syndrome, baby!
That's...that's...that's...stereo...that's...that's...case...case...casebook...
No.
Case.
That's a textbook.
Casebook.
Stockholm Syndrome.
The comics which inspired the movie did it better.
Megatron started out as a pacifist and political activist.
He tried to peacefully overturn the system, but after the senate tried to have him beaten to death, he broke.
What?
Have you tried Project Wingman?
I haven't yet, but I have it.
I own it.
Brother.
I always wanted a brother.
What was I going to say?
I don't remember.
How was A Yummy Mama on Kamiket?
So great!
Um, actually, okay, gosh, my trip was just jam-packed.
From day one, I arrived...I arrived at, uh, in Japan.
And, um, actually, there's another artist I like named Pannomimi.
And she had a collaboration cafe.
That was until...it was ending the first day of Kamiket.
And so I was like, well, I'll be at Kamiket, so I can't go.
So I got...I landed and then immediately went to...went to the cafe.
What a culture thumbnail.
Thank you!
And so I went to...I actually got some footage of that.
I might make, like, a little YouTube short about it or something.
Did you get merch for it?
Oh my gosh, I was so upset!
Because I was...later...I was there later, they closed the merch stuff, so I couldn't get any merch.
So sad.
But, um...
Uh...
They let you film?
Yeah!
So, it was nothing.
Usually they let you film in places like that.
But yeah, so that was day one.
And then...
I met up with someone.
Before I went to the cafe.
The cafe.
Who was it?
Well, Kiara and I didn't get to meet up, unfortunately.
We tried, we did.
Wait, why is my...hold on, my thing keeps getting all messed up.
Kojima.
Oh yeah, totally.
Scarlet Megadodo!
Hello, Minky Megadodo from Scarlet Megadodo.
Thank you, Scarlet Megadodo!
I met up with someone.
Oh my god, I'm the worst.
Sorry to whoever I met up with.
It's truly the sicky brain.
I promise.
It might have been Kojima.
Yeah, you know what?
I met up with Hideo Kojima.
I don't know who I met up with.
Is it Pia?
No, I hung out with Pia after the first day of Comiket.
I hung out...actually, I met up with Ayami Mama.
We didn't really hang out.
She basically came to my hotel to give me...
She gave me...
She gave me tickets for Comiket.
So...
And I gave her Baja Blast.
Ayami, who's Ayami?
Ayami is my mama.
Ayami drew me.
Made me look like this.
And I gave her Baja Blast.
And she was like, you brought all of...
It was like a six pack of Baja Blast.
She was like, you brought all of this with you?
My suitcase was very heavy because I brought that.
And then I brought a bunch of stuff, like old anime merch that I was selling.
And I took it to Mandarake and I sold it.
So like, actually my suitcase was so full.
Baja Blast.
I don't know, what does a Baja Blast taste like?
Yeah, American water.
How much did you get?
Like 300 yen?
Minto fluid.
I don't believe you.
Sweet limey.
Oh,
what does Mountain Dew taste like?
Never had it.
It's not that I don't like carbonated drinks, I can't have them.
Battery acid.
It's mostly orange juice?
What?
No way.
Still not over the thumbnail.
Glad you like it.
Liar.
It's not orange juice.
It said it's mostly orange juice.
Are you calling them a liar?
They sound like a liar.
That's how I learned that Minto Matara never went to Taco Bell to get tacos and Baja Blast.
No, we actually did not do that.
I was not supposed to take her through a car wash.
We didn't do that either.
Just informed that...
What else?
I was just informed what else Puff Puffs could mean.
I mean their puffy cheeks.
When you're doing your new face, I'd make it Dogeza, of course.
What?
I forgive you.
We're not calling you a truther.
I'm okay.
When you play Monster Girl Quest, you'll do all the voices right.
Isn't that a game voiced?
A lot of it.
Sorry for coughing in your ears, by the way.
Coughing baby.
What was the weather like in your home?
It was dry.
It was cold.
But because I got the tickets for Miami Mama, I didn't have to wait super long for...
You know how people get their first train for Comiket and everything like that?
I didn't have to do any of that, which was really nice.
I was super grateful about that.
So I could...
The second day...
The second day, I just got to line up early.
I went for some of the VTuber mamas and papas.
So I...
Can feel the babu.
I got to get a lot of stuff that I did truly want.
Only one thing.
One thing sold out, and that was one of the books by Minyom.
Minyom.
It was one of the Tummy books.
Just any cute cosplayers.
Oh my gosh, I did!
Oh my god.
You guys!
I was so...
I saw a group of Metal Gear cosplayers.
And I was like...
I must get a picture of the Metal Gear cosplayers.
I was like...
I will get the picture of the Metal Gear cosplayers.
And I'm like sitting there, and they're all like kind of...
In their... They're like...
In a circle basically.
You can kind of tell they're a bit of a tight knit group.
Probably because there's not very many Metal Gear cosplayers.
But they were all kind of like just standing there.
And I was standing waiting for them to kind of finish their conversation.
I was like...
I took out like a little snake.
I took out my little snake, and I was like...
I'm going to get them to take a picture with this.
Because it was like a Kaz...
An Ocelot...
A Christmas boss.
Like he had like a red outfit and everything.
It was so cute.
Hold on.
I got a sneaky shot of them.
Let me find it.
Hold on.
I got a... I took a sneak shot.
A snake shot if you will.
Where did I put it?
Oh here.
I can check the picture... I can check the video.
I'm looking.
I'm waiting.
Oh yeah.
There was like...
One guy was like just a regular soldier guy.
There was two Metal Gear Solid 5 Ocelots.
And one Metal Gear Solid 3 Ocelot.
And I was like just sitting there waiting.
And I was like...
And they were like not noticing me at all.
Maybe because they don't have a sixth sense.
I don't know.
And so I was just like okay well I'm gonna move over.
And I'm gonna... There was a cute Marine cosplayer.
So I was like I'll just take a video of her.
And I took a video of her and it's really cute.
And then I was like okay I did that.
And she was like right next to them so I was like okay.
Well now that I'm done with her I'll just go back to them.
And I was like...
They never noticed me.
The entire time.
I was like...
I just want a picture of you.
Stealth master, maybe.
Camo index too high.
PSA, don't just take out your little snake.
No I have to.
I thought they would notice, right?
At a US con recently I was walking by a doujin booth.
Don't really care about them but I caught Mignon's book in the corner of my eye.
And said here is my card, please sir.
Understandable.
Weird, when I take out my little snake at big events I get escorted from the premises.
I was with those snake cosplayers the second day with my mint phantom cardboard box.
What?
What do you mean mint phantom cardboard box?
I did not see that.
I did not see either.
You should nonchalantly play the exclamation point song.
Is that right?
Yeah, I was kind of bummed about it.
I was like I really want a picture of these guys.
But they were deep in their conversation.
I was like okay, I'll just leave.
And then I took a creep shot from the escalator.
It's on Twitter, did you tag me?
Did you tag me?
But...
The thing about Comiket was it was just way too crowded.
Oh my gosh, I love being in the Blue Archive, but I hate being in the Blue Archive area.
Because it was just so...
Oh my god, it was craziness.
Sometimes there would be a table I would want to go to.
And...
Let's just Comiket in general.
No...
This was other level.
This was absolutely other level.
And...
I would want to go to a table and I would never be able to get to it.
Because I'd be like...
I could never reach it.
You think being into the popular thing would be great?
It is great!
I got to get so much stuff!
It was so awesome!
I went last year, worse than that.
Did I go last year?
I don't think I went last year.
Just like when Conquolet was big.
But...
I still think I got a decent amount of stuff.
Enough that my backpack was heavy and hurting me.
So, you know...
I guess I can't complain too much.
I got everything for Blue Archive that I wanted.
Comiket looks cool but scary?
No, don't be scared at all.
It's very actually...
You know, it's a lot of people but it's quite streamlined.
It's actually not so bad.
Like, lines are very organized.
I'd say it's better to...
To go...
Have... Especially if it's your first time.
Go with no expectations.
You know?
You could be like, oh...
Did I see this?
Like, you know...
You can have some artists you want to see.
But...
Especially if you're like, you know, have...
So basically the popular artists are the wall tables.
So...
They are...
The lines are usually like outside and everything.
And it's a much longer wait.
So if you're like...
If you try to hit up like...
If you're like, oh, my favorite artists are wall tables...
You're gonna probably have a bad time.
You're probably gonna have a bad time.
And you...
And if you get in any later than the very beginning...
You might not...
They might sell out.
I miss when Comiket was free though.
I don't think I...
I never went when it was free.
Welcome back, Minto.
Thank you!
And honestly...
There's so many great tables that aren't just wall tables.
Like, so many...
Underrated artists.
One of my favorite things is like...
Walking around and just being like, oh my god, that's so cute.
And just buying it.
Which is what I really wanted to do with Blue Archive.
Obviously, I had some artists that I wanted to pick up from.
And I did.
But...
For some of them, I was just like...
It's just too crowded.
The longest line I waited in was about an hour and a half.
I'd say.
And that was for an artist that is...
That is an official Blue Archive artist, so...
Maybe the second longest line I waited in was Mignon.
Probably.
I got lost trying to find Ikomochi, Fumoko's papa.
So...
That one was a bit of a line too.
But...
If you get in early, it's...
It's, you know...
And...
The thing is, is like...
They do run out of stock sometimes.
But...
It's usually like around the afternoon time that things really start selling out from the popular people.
So...
You're usually good.
You're usually good to like...
Until like 12 PM.
So...
Hope you get better soon.
Thank you!
Yeah...
But I think I got sick of Kamikaze.
So...
When does it start?
1030...
Gonna share your haul or too explicit?
Oh, I posted it on Twitter.
I can share.
Wait, my chat just froze.
Thank you, YouTube.
Thank you.
Hold on, let me grab it.
Let me grab...
My...
My haul.
Let me grab my haul.
Oh...
Okay, so...
I have day 1...
And day 2.
Okie dokie.
So day 1 I got basically all Blue Archive.
Day 1...
Was basically...
All Blue Archive!
So...
Yippee!
Very cute.
My favorite thing was the Koharu stuff on the right side.
I was very, very happy to find that.
Double Ayami.
I know, I feel like I need to give one away.
Because they're both the same.
I never bought from Ayami.
Actually, from Ayami Mama at...
At...
At Comiket.
Because she won't let me pay!
And I was like...
She told me she was going to...
Get me...
She was going to gift me one of her books.
Because I'm in it.
I was like...
Yippee!
But I'll just buy the rest.
Like on, you know...
On...
What's the word?
Booth.
And then...
I see her the day I'm leaving.
She gives me everything!
And I was like...
No!
Mama!
Please, no!
So, that's why there was no Ayami stuff in the haul pictures.
Because...
I was like...
I'm not gonna...
I don't...
I want to pay you for it!
She's so sweet.
I love Ayami Mama.
Hmm...
I get her mental.
Give up and accept it.
No!
She used to give stuff back.
Also, welcome back.
Thank you!
Yeah, I do!
I give her...
I give her like...
The Baha Blast.
I didn't just have her...
Give her Baha Blast, though.
I gave her other stuff, too.
I gave her some...
Some...
Snackies and things.
Yeah.
And then, day 2 haul...
Was...
Ta-da!
I find myself more and more loving...
You know...
Original characters.
Besides, like, a Blue Archive...
Situation.
I find myself really loving original characters.
So...
This is...
Day 2!
And...
Day 2 was like...
Bunch of...
OC...
Stuff.
And also VTubers, so...
Yeah, yeah.
I see Baobao.
Yeah!
I lined up for Ikomochi.
I see Minion art.
Good.
Oh my gosh.
Minion is just...
Was all that merch heavy?
It was very heavy!
In fact, it was heavier day 2 than day 1.
I don't ever learn my lesson.
I like...
Want to...
Bring a...
Like a suitcase.
A rolly suitcase next time I go or something.
But I never learn my lesson.
No.
Bottom left is...
This is actually like...
I saw this artist on Twitter.
Before...
Comiket.
And it's like a...
It's like a...
White out version of Reimu, Miku and Haruhi.
So...
Yeah, yeah.
I didn't know this artist.
I just popped up in my timeline one day.
And...
I thought it was so cute.
And then I saw that the book was going to be at...
Comiket.
So I was like...
I'm gonna go buy it.
But I didn't realize they're the artist for like...
A lot of the AmiAmi...
Like postcards and things too.
So I was like...
Wow!
I really wanted to get this Riko stuff up at the top.
Especially the acrylic.
Mizugi acrylic.
They got Kedama milk.
Some of these were also just artists that I like...
Happened to stumble upon.
I...
It's funny.
For this one...
For this CD...
I was waiting to talk to Mosaic Wave.
Because they have a booth at Comiket.
And...
I was waiting to...
To talk to them.
And...
But some guy was talking to them.
So I was just like...
Hanging out.
And the table next to Mosaic Wave was like...
Hey, by the way, do you know Touhou?
I was like...
Yeah, I love Touhou.
They were like, listen to our album.
It was an album.
It was like a best of album.
That was like...
EDM and jazz.
I was like...
Do you have one that's just jazz?
They were like, yeah, this is my recommendation.
And so...
I got...
You like jazz?
I got the CD of Touhou Jazz.
And then some of you might recognize this artist.
It's Rosary.
So...
Those are my hauls.
From Comiket.
You can get any genre you like with Touhou music.
I know, it's so great, right?
So awesome.
Hold on, I'm sick of this song.
I'm gonna delete it from...
There we go.
Yeah.
So, Comiket was good.
First day, I went out afterwards with Piappi.
And we...
She took me to a...
Like, it's called the Starbucks...
Roastery, I think is what it is.
And...
You didn't find the Sayori Nekopara doujin?
There was a booth for...
Nekopara, but when I got there, it was all sold out.
Thank you for the food!
Thank you!
And it also wasn't in, like, the actual...
It wasn't in the...
Like, doujin halls.
It was in the...
There's a...
So basically, the way Comiket is divided is...
There's east and west halls.
Which are, like, all the doujin stuff.
And then there's a corporate area.
And, um...
That's where...
Like, Yostar was there.
Nekopara stuff was there.
Lots of stuff.
So, uh...
It's just like that one episode of Lucky Star.
Yeah!
So, um...
Check out Heaven Burns Red.
I didn't see the booth!
I didn't see it.
So...
What the hell is happening?
Why is my camera acting all weird?
I got a new iPhone and the tracking on it is being very strange.
Oh, there we go.
I can turn.
Maybe it's my glasses.
But yeah, so...
And then...
In east and west hall, you'll have different...
Or...
Yeah, east and west sides, you'll have different halls.
So it'll be like...
Hall 1 through 7 or something like that.
So, um...
There's so much to explore.
So, so, so much to explore.
And it's very easy to miss things if you don't have, like...
Specific places you're trying to...
Trying to find.
You know, trying to see yourself.
Did you ever have a chance to visit Comiket when ZUN was there selling a new game?
No, this time I've never...
Honestly, I haven't been to Comiket very much.
I think this is my third time.
Third time only.
Having gone, so...
It wasn't actually that...
I've never actually been that much because...
You know...
It's very expensive traveling to Japan in this season.
And I won't...
You won't catch me at summer Comiket either.
But it's very expensive.
The tickets are like massive amount because everybody's traveling for New Year's.
So...
You know...
I only was able to go once before I started VTubing.
I wish I could go someday.
Oh, we can too!
I hope we can.
Yeah.
Did you do anything for New Year's Eve or did you just hang out at your hotel?
Actually, for New Year's Eve...
I mean, my mom and I were supposed to go get unagi.
But my throat was...
killing me that night.
Oh my gosh.
I went out like...
I feel like I did nothing this trip.
I went out shopping for clothes.
I was just like, okay, I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go grab some clothes, whatever.
And...
Praise me because I did not buy very many clothes.
I bought like...
I bought like two, three things.
I saved money.
Well, I spent it all at Comiket.
But...
Sorry,
what was I saying?
Yeah, I went out to buy clothes because I was just like, okay.
And then that evening, I was like, okay...
I'm gonna go eat unagi with Ayami mama.
And...
Not sick, she's a sicko.
She's a sicko.
So...
But then my throat hurt so bad.
I was like, I don't think I can swallow anything.
So...
I stayed...
Home.
And then...
The day after, I was like, oh no.
I'm sick, sick.
No.
And so on New Year's, I stayed in the entire day.
I stayed in my hotel room the entire day.
It was kind of a bummer.
I did go to Kandamyojin the day after.
So on the second, I went to...
Which is the shrine in Harajuku.
Went to Kandamyojin.
No, sorry.
I'm a liar.
Meiji Jingu.
I went to Kandamyojin later.
Sorry.
Meiji Jingu.
I went to...
On the second.
I'm a liar.
But I learned that Meiji Jingu...
Does not do...
You know how you get the fortunes that are like...
Big fortune.
No fortune.
They don't do those.
So...
I got...
It was just like...
Hold on.
I have it around here somewhere.
Where did I put it?
I might have put it in a clear file already.
Filed it away.
So I...
It was just something like...
Hold on.
I want to find it now.
I think it's right over here.
I had it.
I swear.
I had it like just earlier.
I had it just earlier.
I can't find it.
I give up.
I give up so easily.
And so...
It was like...
Basically...
Be determined or something.
So I was like, this sucks.
So...
The day after...
Kandamyojin, I went to...
Why do I keep saying it?
Meiji Jingu, the one in Harajuku.
I went to Kandamyojin, which is the shrine in Akihabara.
And both were just insane.
Crazy busy.
And I pulled my fortune there.
And I got...
So basically there is this one...
There is a fortune...
That's like above bad luck.
Which is like, your luck is coming.
And I pulled that last year too.
I pulled that last year too.
When is my luck gonna come?
When will my luck be here?
Director Wada.
Thank you for the firecracker.
Thank you so much.
Luck.
It means things are looking up.
Maybe.
But they're always looking up.
They're never up though.
They're just looking up.
Just never up.
But!
So the reason I went to Japan in the first place, this trip, was...
For my favorite idol group.
Tempugumi Inc.
They announced that they were disbanding.
They're ending.
They were ending their story.
They announced that.
And so I was like, I must go see them.
One last time.
And what was so cute is...
You know, things you don't really see if you don't get to go to the venue.
Which is like, outside the...
It was at Makuhari Messe, which is pretty big.
But what I love about that venue the most is that...
It's big, but the inside is very small.
So no seat is a bad seat.
Like, it's so easy to see.
And the stage is very high.
It's very easy to...
Thanks for all the 07s.
It's very easy to see.
And so, it was the clearest...
Well, it was like one of the clearest concerts I've ever seen.
It was so great.
But some of the fun things you don't get to see is like...
Outside, they had like a big...
It felt like a festival.
Like, they had a shooting game where you can shoot and get prizes.
And they had like...
One where you pull a string and get prizes.
Just awesome.
It felt really cool to see.
And they also had omikuji.
They also had fortune readings there too.
And so, I...
Pulled it.
Should've gone to the Furude Shrine in Hinamizawa.
That would've cured my sickness.
I pulled my fortune there.
And instead, I got normal luck!
I got normal luck.
So...
I...
I replaced my...
My coming luck with the normal luck.
Because my oshi...
My oshi said I have normal luck.
Kitty.
Thank you for the Pettikitten!
Welcome back.
Thank you!
But yeah, the concert itself was so, so great.
I was really...
I'm really glad because both days I had...
Really nice seats and...
I wasn't like close to the front or anything, but sometimes it's like...
Really nice not being...
So close to the front of a...
To...
The stage, because you kind of get to...
Have the atmosphere...
Of the stadium, you know?
And everything like that.
This time we welcome back the main, not the other way around.
So, it's kind of...
Fun to be like in the middle of it all and get to see...
Because I...
I honestly have not been to very many like...
Big, big concerts.
Many of the concerts that I've been to have been like...
You know, I follow a lot of smaller idols.
Or...
You know, I just couldn't...
Until like...
Until COVID.
Until I became a Vtuber, I couldn't really afford it.
And so...
Like, the Japan travels and everything.
So then obviously during COVID, I couldn't go because there was no way to go.
And so...
You know.
Normal person, thank you for the 50 gifted, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
You performed in a few big concerts, but nothing like, you know...
Like a...
Stadium size or anything like that.
Event hall size.
So...
Yeah, it's just...
I haven't really... I guess I haven't really processed it, I think.
Because I...
I don't know.
I'm waiting for my breakdown moment.
Because I cried a lot during the show, but...
Obviously, I didn't want to break down crying because I...
Didn't want to like, just miss...
What was going on.
It was so fun, it was still in the moment.
And then every time I wanted to cry, I would be like...
Like in a car or on a train in front of people.
It was so cool.
It'll hit you when you least expect it, maybe.
And it was just a lot, because it was like...
I watched...
Fana's graduation.
The same morning of...
So I was like...
It was a...
Very...
Emotional time for me.
The combo sounds rough.
I think I'm... I think I'm feeling a little numb about it right now.
Just, it's one of those like, defense mechanisms, maybe.
The Narissa call-in was rough.
But...
I worry for people, because...
You know, I don't want people to be like...
I don't want to be into VTubers anymore, because...
You know, it's kind of similar with idols, it's just like they just...
I get too invested and then they're gone.
But it's still...
You should still...
Still...
Have fun with it while you can, you know.
You know.
Everything in life goes away.
So true.
After life too, apparently.
Since my idol groups, my idols are leaving me also.
But...
Yeah, the concert was just so-so.
I'm really... I'm just really grateful that...
I was able to go at all, so...
And I'm only really able... I was only really able to go because of you guys, so...
Thank you, I do really, really appreciate it.
That I was able to experience that moment.
Because of you guys, so thank you.
You can cry now, man.
You just want to hear me cry, right, you freak?
You just want to hear me cry.
I don't want to cry right now.
Cry, cry, cry.
Cry, Vtuber, cry.
But other than that, the show, the live was two days.
I didn't really do much.
I really didn't do much, because I was like...
I got sick.
I didn't want to go so many places, because it was cold and I was sick.
And I was just trying to rest up for...
For the concert.
And the concert happened in two days, and then I went home.
My friend is a sapling.
I dealt with the graduation last year, so I tried to help him as best as I could.
Aww, you're a good friend.
It's like times like this when...
Everybody is here for each other, you know.
We've had a heck of a 2025.
Already, I know, we're only eight days in.
Nine for some of you, maybe.
We're only a week in.
And I've already...
I've already... I'm at my limit.
I'm at my limit.
It's okay, you watched TF1.
That's what counts.
I'm so glad that... I'm so happy my plane had it.
I watched that.
I watched a movie called The Fall Guy.
Which had Ryan Reynolds in it.
It was about... I don't know, it was just like, fall guys.
But it was about a guy that does stunt...
Gosling!
Oh my god!
Ryan Gosling in it!
Wait, what do you mean they gaslit me hard?
Wait, am I... Hold on, I'm gonna look it up.
Wait, it is...
Are you guys gaslighting me?
Was Ryan Reynolds actually all along?
It's Reynolds.
Wait.
Hold on, I'm gonna look it up.
The Fall Guy.
Guy.
I put the fall gut.
What?
Gosling!
See, I was right!
I was right!
Gosh, you guys gaslighting me.
You guys said... The other one.
No, you said Reynolds.
No, you're gaslighting me.
You're gaslighting me.
Who said Reynolds first?
Oh wait, yeah I did.
And then you guys said it was...
Wait,
I said it was Gosling and then you guys said it was Reynolds.
No, sorry.
Hold on.
I said it was Gosling.
No!
I said it was Reynolds and you said it was Gosling.
Gosling.
I wonder if I could get a shoutout for my dog, Mr. Sweaters.
Mr. Sweaters!
I mean to hear you give a proper goodbye.
Sorry about your dog, Rodrigo.
No, Mr. Sweaters sounds such a cute name.
That's such a cute name.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for another 50.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Mr. Sweaters.
Oh no, this music is kind of...
Wait, what do you mean?
Fall guy has Gosling, free guy has 2021.
Wait, free guy 2021 has Reynolds.
Why did they do this to me?
We all mix up names.
Don't feel too bad about it, Enya.
Thank you for another 50, you horrible person.
What the hell?
Thank you so much.
Another 50?
Are you okay?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Okay, so thank you for the thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
But yeah, I watched the fall guy.
That was cute.
I liked it.
I thought it was pretty cute.
And then I watched Transformers.
I literally, I started Joker 2.
I think I got like 5 minutes into it.
I was like...
I don't know.
I didn't watch it.
I feel like there was something else I watched and I don't remember what it was.
Joker.
The correct choice.
But the juggler.
It's kind of wack to be honest.
I heard that like the guy who made the original Joker really doesn't like the original Joker.
And so Joker 2 kind of retcons a bunch of stuff.
From what I've heard.
I don't know if that's like a true thing.
He's mad that people idolize the Joker.
I don't know.
He doesn't like Joker fans.
That's so silly.
Thank you!
He killed it for the fans.
Blue Destiny, why are all your O's?
Did your O key break?
I liked the first Joker though.
I think that...
Like...
I think he was a very...
You know, sympathetic character.
Kind of like one of those movies where it's just like...
Some people are born bad, but when they're pushed to their limits, you know.
Situations.
If Mint has become the Joker, does that mean the director hates us also?
I'm not the Joker yet.
I will become the Joker one day.
Thank you.
You know who is also a sympathetic character?
Megatron.
Less so!
That guy kind of turned into an asshole.
Did I like it?
Yeah.
Did I like him as an asshole?
Obviously.
But...
That guy...
Literally, it just... Someone needed to tell him to chill out.
But he was kind of awesome.
He was the only one who stood up against Suspicious Prime.
He was like, I'm gonna get my ass whooped for this, but I don't care.
Orion told him to chill out at the Noah.
What's the thumbnail?
It's Ear of the Snake, baby!
Still need to watch Transformers 1.
It's so good.
I didn't know it was animated.
I thought it was a live action.
Stupid silly.
But it's animated so well.
It looks so good.
It looks so good and the characters are very fun and lovable.
And...
All around, I think it's really good.
TF1 watch-along?
Maybe.
I saw a comment recently.
I'm not getting one guide or anything, but I did see a comment from someone.
I was like, I wish Minto would do watch-alongs of things she hasn't seen before.
Since I, you know, I think I did Indiana Jones before.
And then I, you know, I've already seen those movies.
So...
That got me thinking maybe I should do more that are things that I haven't seen.
Thumbnail of Phantom Namia.
Goonies next?
I have not seen the Goonies.
Twilight, I've seen Twilight though.
Ignore that guy, I want Beast Wars watch-along.
Okay, but it's been a long enough time from Beast Wars that I think if I watch it now...
Like I remember certain things.
Typically, it's like I remember a storyline of something, but I can't remember such specific parts.
So it would still be like...
To me, you know what I mean?
I haven't watched Sonic 3 yet.
I haven't even watched Sonic 2 yet.
No, you guys can have my...
You can come for my throat!
Take it!
No, you're sick?
Okay.
I don't want your ghost germs.
Hold on, coughing baby.
Spider-Man watch-along.
Wait, I kind of want to watch original Spider-Man though.
Well, you know, like...
Peter Park...
What's his name?
Tobey Maguire!
You know what I really love?
Quoting is...
That one in Spider-Man 3 when he's like...
I miss the part where that's my problem.
Have you guys seen that edit where it's only him going...
I love that edit so much!
Why are you writing Orion Gosling?
Mint is suffering from Lumbago.
What's that?
Bully Maguire.
I miss the part where that's my problem.
My only problem with watch-along is that I'm at work unless it's Thursday or Sunday.
So I have to VOD them.
I miss the part where that's my problem.
That does sound like your problem.
My problem.
Wait, do you guys know what I'm talking about?
Seriously.
Do I have to pull up this clip?
No?
Okay, okay.
Can I watch it anyway?
Can we watch it anyway?
Can we watch it again?
Who am I?
Wait!
You guys, did you hear?
I got a new keyboard.
Okay, are you ready for...
Are you ready for real creamy keyboard action?
Are you ready for this?
I'm just gonna write... I miss the part where that's my problem.
I'm moving my mic.
I miss the part where that's my problem.
Stop playing with rocks.
Mr. Krabwalking sound effect.
Maybe that's a good thing.
Can that be your tissue?
Snake!
You can always be my tissue.
Here, let me blow my nose.
Only one of my nostrils is...
is stuffy right now.
Okay, let's watch the part where that's my problem.
I love this video.
I love this video, it's so funny.
I miss the part where that's my problem.
That should be good.
Oh, I think I missed a little bit off the top.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
Let's watch.
Yeah, whatever.
Okay.
He's such an asshole.
I miss the part where that's my problem.
Great power.
It's so sad.
It's not even there.
In spite of everything you've done for them.
Eventually they will hate you, my father.
Because I miss the part where that's my problem.
Wrong answer!
See ya, chump.
Oh my god, this is seven minutes long!
I miss the part where that's my problem.
I have your little girlfriend and some children here.
Save them if you can.
I miss the part where that's my problem.
He's such an asshole.
Peter Parker if he stayed in his own way.
It's so good.
I miss the part where that's my problem.
All the times you miss the part where that's your problem...
make me sad.
I thought you'd learn the meaning of responsibility.
All the parts where you miss the part where that's your problem...
make me sad.
Bully McGuire strikes again.
Oh gosh!
That's so funny.
Such a good edit.
Just look up Spider-Man Trilogy but he always missed the part where that's his problem.
You'll find the video.
It's so funny.
Can you play it again?
I miss the part where that's my problem.
That's good.
That's so good.
I miss the part where that's my problem.
Okay guys.
There's one more thing I wanted to do tonight.
And that's what I want to do is...
I want to make my 2025...
Why do I say it like that?
My 2025 resolutions.
If you hold your breath until your brain goes into panic mode, you can temporarily force your sinuses to clear themselves.
I don't...
I don't think that's healthy.
Don't think you should do that.
I mean, I don't have to breathe.
I'm a ghost.
I just do it to sound more natural.
You know, to not freak you guys out.
Like this.
That's all, you know, sound like I was...
Can someone reverse that?
What did I say in reverse?
Can someone...
It sounded like I just talked in reverse.
I just...
I missed the part where that's my problem.
Gives yourself a panic attack to fix a minor inconvenience.
What did I just say just then?
Something dirty.
Dirty.
Oh wait, let's see if I can actually say I missed the part where that's my problem.
Okay, hold on.
Let me type it out.
I missed the part where that's my problem.
M-E-L-B-O-R-B M-Y-S-T-A-H-T E-R-E-H-W T-R-A-P E-H-T D-E-S-S-I-M I.
Okay.
Someone play this back forward, okay?
Someone play this back forward.
M-E-L-B-O-R-B S-T-A-T-B-E-R-O T-R-A-P-E-P-T Wait, hold on.
Redo!
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Let me get, like, the T-H.
Okay, let me put, like, the T-H's.
Okay.
Okay, alright.
Let's try again.
Okay.
M-E-L-B-O-R-B S-T-A-T-B-E-R-O T-R-A-P-E-P-T D-E-S-S-I-M-I Okay.
Okay, you have it.
You have it.
Tell me what I said.
Tell me if I got it right.
What?
Okay.
Alright.
I can't.
I love it, though.
Strange New Year's Resolution.
No!
A New Year's Resolution!
2025 goals!
I missed the clip where that's Mint's problem.
Okay.
I think...
I'm on the first one.
Would an OG song be a good goal?
That's actually what I have written literally right here.
Release an original song.
I want to do that this year.
What's in my face?
I want to release an original song this year.
I want to.
You have one.
No.
Not yet.
But I will.
I will.
Yeah.
I actually have been in the talks with a...
With a...
Someone.
About an original song.
So...
Maybe.
Sooner than you think.
Perhaps.
Maybe.
Yes.
Secret, secret.
Going along with that though.
Going along with this though.
I also want to finally get voice lessons.
I've been talking about it!
For as...
For so long.
I want to finally...
Go do voice lessons and like...
Properly retrain my voice and everything.
I'm really determined about that.
I have to find a good voice teacher.
Let me know.
I hope all your 2025 dreams come true.
Thank you!
You have something on your nose?
Where?
Oh, now you acknowledge my nose, huh?
Now you acknowledge my nose, huh?
You never wanted to acknowledge my nose before, but now...
Oh, now it's fine.
Problem, that's my that's where part the mist eye.
My, oh my gosh, I got a new camera, but I don't think it's very good.
I keep like...
Can we get a close up nose pic?
Sure.
Nose!
Oh my gosh, if you only see the arrow, it looks like I'm Avatar the Last Airbender.
I'm Avatar the Last Airbender.
Thank god one guy didn't believe he had a nose.
No!
I was, you guys, I was right.
You were right.
About Ryan.
And Ryan.
Mr. Ryan.
2025 Mint performs at Budokan.
Okay, let's aim for some realistic stuff here now, okay?
Let's aim for things that are doable.
Maybe.
Perhaps.
Wait, they have hearts in their eyes.
This is how my eyes have always looked.
They like?
Can wisps get jetpacks?
You guys don't need them though.
My hat!
You guys don't need jetpacks.
Literally, wisps are like floating around.
You have a built-in jetpack.
It's funny though, because...
I know your name, like you guys are wisps and all, but I never think of you as dead.
I don't think you guys are dead, truly.
Because...
I don't want you guys to...
I don't want you guys to become spirits.
I don't want you guys to become ghosts.
You only become a ghost when you have regret, you know?
I want you guys to have a very happy and fulfilling life.
So you don't have to become a ghost.
You don't have to become a wisp.
So...
So I never think of you guys as dead.
She's ghost keeping.
We didn't have to die.
Well, that's what a wisp is.
Minto, you have to let us go.
Blah blah blah.
Accident blah.
Ten years ago blah blah blah.
Blah blah blah.
How could we go see a ghost in a cafe if we're not dead?
You have a sixth sense.
I see dead people.
But you're not that guy because he sucks.
I regret not going to your concert.
Can I be a ghost now?
No!
Nope.
Sixth sense?
You have enough to buy a gumball.
Neither alive nor truly dead.
I regret not having a jetpack.
Why did you...
Will that be what makes you happy?
A jetpack?
Will that truly solve all your problems?
After Minto returned, wisps were taken from the battle.
Neither truly alive nor truly dead.
Undying shadows and a world of lights.
Now in front of you, I can finally die.
Not all, but some.
Coast keep girl boss.
I think if you get a jetpack you'll actually become a wisp.
I don't trust you guys.
I don't think I trust you guys with one.
First you have to go to jetpack training school.
Show me your certificate and then you can get a jetpack, okay?
I was always trying to show my friend your singing, but he AFKed.
But he'd be AFK at the good parts.
But then he caught your concert at Anime North and loved it.
Anime North?
Wait, that's a truck, right?
Yay!
I'm glad he liked it.
Thank you.
The parking lot one.
Jetpack school?
I missed the part where that was my problem.
You want a jetpack?
Two can play that game.
I missed the part where that was my problem.
Let's see.
My third goal for 2025 is to organize a big event.
Event.
Maybe more than one.
I want to at least do one.
Maybe like a big tournament or a karaoke thing.
Or something.
I want to organize a big event.
Some sort of thing involving a bunch of other Vtubers.
I was thinking about it earlier.
I was just like...
You know, like...
I'm not into Marvel Rivals, which is the hot stuff right now.
And it makes me sad because I want to collab with people.
But everyone's playing it and I have no interest.
And I kind of hope that hopefully soon there will be a new game.
Like a new Among Us or a new Lethal Company.
That comes out.
I was watching...
Sorry.
Just earlier I was watching someone play...
I think it was an old, old VOD from years ago of someone playing Among Us.
And I was just like...
I'll miss this.
Lockdown protocol.
But even then I think...
It's not as popular anymore.
You know.
Wipes your nose, milady.
Oh, thank you, Indy.
Some people are getting back into Lethal.
Maybe, hopefully.
I was like, man, I want to have games like this again.
They're fun.
But also it's hard for me to ask people for collabs.
So it's Fortnite, Miku collab.
Oh boy, baby.
So...
I don't know.
But I want to organize something big.
I've been brainstorming.
Something.
Something, maybe.
Something, something.
Yeah.
My next goal...
This one might... I don't know if this one will be possible.
I know we just reached 300k.
But I want to reach 444... 444...
K.
Wait, not K.
Wait, get to 4...
Get to 4444 subscribers.
Subscribers.
Speaking of...
444...
Wait, how much do I have?
It's a 3, right?
If I added one more, it would be a million.
444... 444...
I don't know if it will be possible.
It might be, you know...
But we can aim for it.
I'll do my best.
Alright.
44444444444...
Clatka is a pretty fun Lethal Company-like game.
It's in early access right now.
Let me type that up.
Let me look it up later.
Thank you.
444... Why did I reach 666666?
Because I don't think that's possible in 2025.
I will work hard to be more fun.
And have more people want to subscribe to me.
They just have to hate us even more.
Even more than I already do?
I don't know if that's possible.
Wait, have more fun.
I'm having fun!
What I say is I have a ball around my ankle.
I'm having fun.
You can't see the gun being pointed at me from behind the screen.
Oh, this is so fun.
I'm having fun.
I love being ridiculed online every day.
Please, I'm having so much fun.
Please call me sick more.
Please call me a freak even more.
I'm having so much fun.
Hurt me more.
She despises and she loathes us.
She curses our houses.
That's the curse.
Marrying Mike Tyson's ass!
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I missed the part where that's my problem in reverse.
No, it wasn't.
It was the first time.
Has anyone flipped it back yet?
I'm gonna go check Twitter.
I'm so curious if it sounds good.
I really wanna hear it.
Has anyone flipped it back yet?
Wait!
Is this it?
Wait, I wanna hear it.
Okay, it's gonna be stream-ception for a second.
No, you have to flip it!
This is my...
I'm having so much fun.
Hurt me more.
That's my problem in reverse.
I'm so curious if this is the first time.
Has anyone flipped
it back yet?
I'm so curious if this is the first time.
I missed the part where that's my problem in reverse.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it worked!
I'm such a genius!
Yes!
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Oh sorry, I keep dabbing my eyes.
Oh gosh.
It sounds so good.
Okay.
Oh gosh, okay.
Oh yeah, I do have my meeting soon-ish.
In about 20 minutes.
Okay, my fifth goal for this year.
I want to finish 50 games.
I want to finish so many games.
50 games, that might be kind of crazy.
I don't know how many games I finish normally.
But I want to finish 50 games.
Oh gosh.
It's like a game a week?
That's totally doable.
We're about to finish two games.
We're going to finish Indiana Jones soon and we're going to finish Devil May Cry.
And I count also games that are one shot games too.
So we'll have a bunch of games.
That we can play.
50 games baby.
We got this.
This next one.
I wrote these down.
This is all I wrote down though.
So I want to come up with at least 10 goals.
So I wrote down this one.
I want to have a 3D debut.
I think the podcast will make a comeback this year.
I'm not sure, to be honest.
Later on I got to S rank in Tetriol listening to Karaoke Relay.
I checked that off my list of my M and M summer list.
Congrats!
Oh my god.
That's cool.
3D Minto.
I know I have 3D now, but I want to have a proper 3D debut.
And I want to have it with the new model that I've been getting.
I look forward to that.
It might be a little bit longer.
Can you beat Minesweeper?
Yeah, probably.
Probably.
Okay guys.
Number 7, beat Minesweeper.
Number 7.
Beat Minesweeper.
That's number 7 of my goals for 2025.
Feel better soon, me and Tom, Minto Appi arrive.
Thanks for ordering it.
Splinter Cell series playthrough.
Maybe.
We'll see.
I have so many other games I got to get through too.
What should number 8 be?
New outfit maybe?
That's a given though, right?
More collabs with friends?
Yeah, I think that's a good one.
More collabs with friends.
I think that's a good one.
I don't reach out very much to people.
I don't reach out very much to people, I think.
Desert bus in one sitting.
How else would you do it if not one sitting?
I'm going to combine this one.
To collab with friends.
Slash, make more friends.
Yeah, I'm going to put it like...
I think if I make more friends I can collab with them.
Probably.
Get sponsored by something related to Metal Gear.
I could try.
I could try putting that.
I'm scared to put that though.
Maybe like...
Get a cool sponsorship.
Like that.
Maybe.
That's something like I really, really love.
Have you played Squirrel with a Gun?
It's a short semi-Kusoge with a lot of Metal Gear references.
I have not.
Didn't you literally fulfill that yesterday?
True.
It is 2585.
Go fulfilled.
Yeah, get more.
Cool sponsorships.
There we go.
More cool sponsorships.
Ships.
Okay.
Get a Nendoroid figure?
Oh yeah, that would be good too.
Maybe...
How do I want to put it?
Lambda!
I'm doing my best.
I would, you know...
I'm already dead, but I would die again.
Inscription.
I've seen people play it, but I get really intimidated by playing card games on stream, I'll be honest.
Sound like that without voice lessons?
Screw Nendos.
Get a Figma?
I didn't say Nendoroid, I don't know.
Maybe get more Minto merch?
Maybe.
Get cool Minto merch.
Maybe like that.
I know some people are like, Nendoroid, listen to that.
But...
I think...
I think maybe I need to grow a little bit more.
To get those kinds of opportunities.
I'd buy lame Minto merch too.
Any merch I put out has to be cool, right?
So...
Maybe this is a good amount.
Maybe.
10 things that I want to try and do this year.
Maybe then at the end of the year we can...
We can see if we hit any of these.
We'll see.
I'm really curious to see how many games I'll be finished.
New outfit?
I think that's a given.
It's not really a goal of mine.
Because it's already a given.
But I think these are things that it's like...
If I...
Can accomplish it, then it'll be pretty cool.
Official Minto literal cardboard box merch.
Pack all your stuff into your official... Are you moving?
Pack all your things into the official cardboard box.
Perfect for hiding it too.
What's the current completed game count?
I have no idea.
I have no idea because I have not kept track.
So starting now.
Starting now I'll be keeping track every time I beat a game.
Now we gotta keep track.
Starting now.
Now.
This literal second.
We'll also keep track for you.
If you can help, that'd be great.
But I'm also gonna make like a spreadsheet too.
I'm gonna make a spreadsheet.
Will there be a breath hole?
No.
What if Minto merch packed in a custom-designed cardboard box?
What about something crazy like official streaming host of a cool non-vtuber, non-anime event?
Wait...
What do you mean, wait?
Beat the Metal Gear Pachinko machine?
Oh god!
Oh, MGS Con!
MGS Con, MGS Con.
True, I forgot.
Oh gosh.
Well, I didn't...
There's been a lot going on, okay?
And I also have sick jet lag brain.
Give me a break!
Number 11, stay healthy.
Yeah, I think this is a good 10.
I've completed 43 games.
Oh no, she's referring back to her know-how.
43 games, like last year?
I did 43 last year.
Well then, 50 is completely doable.
50 is like...
Yeah, and I came back in April, exactly.
So...
50 is totally doable.
Hmm...
I just want to share, I proposed to my girlfriend on New Year's and she said yes!
I showed her your streams and she became an instant wisp.
We both missed you.
Nevermore!
I mean, our girlfriend.
Our fianc.
Congratulations to our...
Engagement!
Congratulations to our engagement!
But seriously, I'm happy for you!
Congratulations!
Wow.
Nice.
Imagine getting a marriage proposal.
Wow.
I'm happy for you.
Things Minto will never get.
She's so parasocial.
Stop!
Is there a penalty for not completing this list?
Okay, but some of this stuff I can't help.
I can't help if people don't want to hire me for sponsorships.
And I can't help it if I don't make it to the amount of subscribers.
That's not up to me.
Just be more marketable.
I mean, there's something that gets to me, you know.
I know I'm not very marketable, I guess.
That's okay, I'll do my best.
I think they clearly meant a penalty for Wisps, not Minto.
Why would there be a penalty for you guys?
What if I just didn't do it then?
I could do it so I could watch you get punished.
Watch you get punished.
Punished Wisps.
I would like to wear some Minto shirts, please.
Shirts, you say?
I will consider it.
My plushie on pre-order says that you're very marketable.
Don't judge what I don't judge.
A very special marketable.
Hmm...
But,
you know.
More so than the...
Than the... What's it called?
Than the...
Whatever's the...
Opportunities.
I still have a lot of fun, so...
If anything, I think that's worth much more.
I think I would...
Imagine, you know, you could get every opportunity in the world.
But if, you know, it's in a crappy situation...
Then...
Or if you're not having fun, you're not enjoying it, then...
I think that would be...
Be worse than, you know, if you never got any opportunities at all.
So...
Thank you Carlamel!
Thank you for the icon!
I hear couples channels are pretty marketable.
Is that true?
Do people watch couples channels?
What, do you want to become a family channel?
Yeah?
Wait, really?
Really?
I volunteer.
Does Fuwamuko count?
I don't...
Well, they are definitely...
They are a pair.
I would not say a couple, maybe.
I don't know if I would call it a...
They are truly a family channel.
In that they are family.
Don't tell that to Fuwawa.
I know their... I know their...
Their tastes.
I know their tastes.
Their sweet home Alabama tastes.
Thank you for the pink!
So punny.
My mom called me to tell you that she loves your streams and to let you know that you are very marketable.
No way!
She subscribed as craftmom1.
What?
That's so cute!
No way did she call you to be like...
No way she calls you to say that.
You want a cute girl?
Meant to pick me instead.
Would you love me even with my snotty nose?
Would you love me even if my nose was dripping down my face the entire stream?
Stuffed Sharky!
Thank you for the 20 gupter!
Thank you!
Snot makes me extra cute.
What if I make it extra big?
Oh shoot, my meeting.
Is soon.
Happy New Year!
Allow me to make it big.
Now it's even bigger.
Guys, I think I'm sick.
Guys, I think I'm...
I think I'm sick in the head.
I'm leaking ectoplasm.
Big ectoplasm drip.
Minto beanie, hoodie, gloves, cards, stickers, decals, air fresheners, bags, even a pen.
You want a bunch of practical stuff.
I appreciate it.
Couples content is so last year.
Come fist fight me behind a Wal-Mart.
Wal-Mart or Denny's?
What about the Waffle House?
Isn't that where everybody fights, is the Waffle House?
But yeah, let's do our best, you guys, with achieving all of these goals for 2025.
I had a lot of fun in 2024.
I know I came back and everything.
So, I'll do my best for 2025.
I can't think anymore.
I think I've leaked my brain out.
How about releasing voice packs?
You might just have to wait.
And see.
Actually, part of my meeting is about merchandise, so...
I don't think these went through.
Superliminal, thank you for the stream lives.
Best of luck achieving your 2025 goals and more.
Thank you!
Alrighty, thank you!
We'll keep pushing you until you can achieve everything you want to, Minto.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Glad I heard my cat.
Okay, I'm going to go rest now.
So I will see you guys...
Well, I have my meeting and then I'm going to drink the rest of this.
Sleep medicine.
Yeah!
Meeting with your bed.
After.
Otsumito!
It's been a while since I did just a chat stream.
So I hope you guys had fun.
I hope you guys liked it.
I didn't say so much about Japan, because honestly so much didn't happen.
But I'm glad we could talk still about lots of fun stuff.
Also I missed the part where that's my problem.
Otsumito!
Bye bye!
Good night!